Time flies when you’re having fun!
But time is a constant right?
So, why does it feel like it goes at different
speeds?
Hey guys Julia here for the last time
Fascinating research into time reveals just
our fluid our sense of time really is.
Ever been in a car accident and it seemed
to unfold in slow motion?
Well a study published in the journal Frontiers
in Human Neuroscience found that we feel like
time slows down when an object is coming toward
us and time speeds up when it’s not moving
or moving away from us.
The researchers believe this has to do with
threat perception.
Parts of your brain fire that handle how we
think about ourselves in relation to what’s
going on around us.
So when something comes towards us, we need
to plan what to do.
If something moves away from us, that might
makes us relax, as it’s no longer a threat.
Time slowing down or speeding up is really
all in your head.
Another study published in the journal Philosophical
Transactions of the Royal Society B: Biological
Sciences found that time slows down if the
stimulus is novel.
The researchers think this could be because
you’re taking in more information at once
than you normally do.
So if something new is heading right towards
you, time might feel like it slows wayyyy
down.
And you don’t have to wait for a life threatening
situation to experience time slowing down.
One study published in the journal PLOS one
found that purposely falling 15 stories does
the trick.
The researchers had test subjects bungee jump
15 stories and estimate how long they had
been falling for.
The terrified participants said they fell
for about 4 seconds when really it was only
2.5.
And to test the idea that the slowing of time
perception happens because our brain is taking
in more information -- like a slower computer
churning through data -- the researchers gave
the participants watches that flashed numbers
faster than they'd be able to read under normal
circumstances…
They figured, if they were sucking in all
this info, then they would read the numbers
on the watch face, but as the participants
fell, they still couldn’t do it.
So time didn’t reeeaaallly slow down for
them.
It seemed slower in retrospect because of
the emotional charge of the situation.
But time seems to speed up too.
Most of the time shifting we experience happens
when we get older.
We settle into routines and every day just
becomes a familiar blur of work and stress.
Some researchers believe time picks up speed
as we age because each moment becomes a smaller
percentage of our lives.
When we’re 10, a year is a tenth of our
lives, when we’re thirty, it's only 1/30th.
This ‘proportional' theory, as it’s called,
was put forth in 1877 by Paul Janet.
But it doesn’t explain everything.
Studies like one published in the journal
Acta Psychologica found that time doesn’t
actually speed up for older people.
When they are asked out count off a minute,
they don’t do it any faster than a younger
person.
Or when asked about how long the past month
felt to them, there wasn’t much difference
between people of different ages.
So our perception doesn’t change as we get
older.
Our memory of time does.
The researchers proposed that novel experiences
are the most memorable and as we get older,
we have fewer novel experiences.
They also point to a phenomenon called 'forward
telescoping'.
This where you think something memorable feels
like it happened only yesterday, when really
it was TWENTY years ago, like when Toy Story
hit theaters…
. Basically memorable events are clearer in
our memories than less memorable ones, so
we wrongfully assume they happened more recently.
Once you realize your error, man do you feel
old.
Speaking of time flying by.
It seems like just yesterday I joined DNews
for the first time.
But really it was over a year ago!
But now it’s time to say goodbye.
While I’m saying goodbye to DNews, I’ll
still be around on the internet.
Come find me on my Tumblr, That’s So Science
and on twitter @julia_sci.
Thank you so much for being the best fans
and for all your thoughtful comments!
Got any other science questions for the
DNews team?
Thanks for watching DNews.
I’ll see you around.